مستشفى ماونت سيناي بروكلين
صغير نسبيًا ، لكنه
غمره
منذ أن بدأ الوباء ، وهو أحد
أصدقائي الأعزاء ، وهو زميلي في الكلية
منذ أربع سنوات.  ميلاني
مولوي طبيبة حاضرة هناك
قامت بعمل مذكرات لنا لتظهر لنا كيف
تبدو الحياة على الخطوط الأمامية ، مرحباً
اسمي د.  ميلاني مولوي أنا
طبيبة حاضرة في Mount Sinai
Brooklyn و Mount Sinai في كوينز. أنا
في طريقي إلى العمل ،
لقد طلبنا من صديقي القديم أن يوضح لنا
كيف تبدو الحياة في يوم ما في أحد
مستشفيات نيويورك للحصول على بعض الدعك.
سأحصل على أقنعة درع للوجه أحتاج إلى
أن أكون آمنًا على وجهي للدكتور.  ميلاني
مولوي ، هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي الجديد
الذي سأبدأ بنفسي في غرفة الطوارئ في
مستشفى ماونت سيناي بروكلين
التي دخلت فيها وقد قالوا إن
كل شخص قد تم تنبيبه ويبدو
أنه صحيح في الواقع يتم تناول معظم حقائبنا من
قبل المرضى المنبوبين.
المرضى الذين لا يستطيعون التنفس من تلقاء
أنفسهم والذين يستخدمون جهاز التنفس الصناعي ،
كل شخص تقريبًا ذهب مرة أخرى وأنا تقريبًا
مريض مشفر منذ أن
بدأ الوباء ، وقد غمرت أكثر من 1200
حالة من حالات الكورونا في دفع
المستشفى إلى مائة وخمسين بالمائة
من سعته اليوم ، هناك 43
شخصًا في القسم ، لكن يجب أن
أقول إنه يعمل بشكل أفضل بكثير مما كان عليه
قبل أسبوعين عندما كان لدينا 86 إلى 96
من القسم وأربعين شخصًا يصعدون على متن الطائرة ،
وكان الأمر صعبًا حقًا كان سيئًا حقًا
في العناية المركزة  الوحدة ، إنه مشهد مشابه
، أردت فقط أن أعطيكم يا رفاق ،
لقد ألقيت نظرة سريعة على وحدة العناية المركزة ، لذلك لدينا
وحدة العناية المركزة الكاملة لدينا كل مريض هنا
على جهاز التنفس الصناعي كما ترون
ليس ضخمًا
ولكنه ممتلئ تمامًا ، كل سرير ممتلئ
، سأحاول الذهاب إلى الخزان ، هذه هي
حركة المرور السريعة لدينا منذ ذلك الحين فقط كما
تعلم من العثور على الوزغة ، يمكنك أن ترى
أنك تعلم أنه يتعين علينا إخبار الناس بأنه لا يمكننا
اختبار  لهم من أجل شركتي القديمة ، سجل
المسرح الصباحي هنا فريق رائع
ومن ثم لدينا مناطق
منفصلة للأشخاص الذين يتلقون العلاج
للأطباء الذين يعملون على مدار الساعة لإنقاذ
الأرواح ، هناك امتيازات عرضية واحدة من
الأشياء المفضلة لدي هي التجميد العميق.
متحمس للغاية لأن لدينا Shake
Shack ،
لذا فأنا أنتظر وضع مريضي التالي
في غرفة ، هذا مختلف
لأن الداعم معظم المرضى الأكبر سنًا
الذين رأيناهم اليوم هو في
أوائل العشرينات من عمره ، أعتقد أن شيئًا واحدًا
نحن '  إعادة التعلم هو أننا لا
نعرف حقًا ما الذي سيأتي به شخص
ما ولن يتطور ، كل شخص مصاب بفيروس كورونا ،
بعض الأشخاص يعانون أيضًا من نوبات قلبية
في نفس الوقت الذي يحدث فيه هذا الأمر ، وهذا يجعل
الأمور أكثر صعوبة الآن خلال
أيامي بشكل جيد يوم المستشفى الخاص بي  انتهى الأمر
، لم يكن هذا أسوأ يوم مررت به ،
لكنه دائمًا ما يكون مستنزفًا جدًا
، ومن الصعب أن تعتقد أن
بعض مرضاك الذين قالوا إنك تم تشخيصك
اليوم قد لا يكونون هنا غدًا
عندما تعود من أجل ورديةك أو  أنت تعرف
كل هذا لا أعرفه من نظامه الغذائي
للدكتور.  لا تنتهي التحديات مالوي مع
تحولها إلى أرملة تربي ثلاثة
أطفال بمفردها ، لذا فهي تقترب
الساعة العاشرة ليلاً وفي طريقي إلى المنزل
حصلت على FaceTime من طفلي الأصغر
لأي شيء هو أصعب جزء على ما
أعتقد  هذا يشبه مجرد أن أكون وحدي
عندما أعود إلى المنزل مع العلم أنك تعلم
أن رعاية طفلي
ستعود إلى المنزل ، فإن مساعدي سيذهبون إلى المنزل
وأنا وحدي ، ومهما كانت الحالة التي يعيشها
أطفالي ، ولم يتبق لي الكثير
لي
في اليوم التالي د.  يستغرق مالوي لحظة
للتحدث إلينا ، من الجنون
ما تراه وتتعامل معه
هل سبق لك تجربة أي شيء مثل هذا
أبدًا وأنت تعلم أنه حتى
الأشخاص الأكبر سنًا مثل الأطباء الأكبر سنًا هم
كما لو لم أر هذا من قبل في بلدي.
هناك شيء واحد أعلم أنه
لم يُسمح لك بإظهاره لنا وهو المشرحة ، حيث
يوجد الآن شاحنتان كبيرتان للجرارات
ومقطورات مبردة
ومليئة بالجثث ملفوفة في أكياس بلاستيكية بيضاء
قيل لي إنهما يمكنها استيعاب 50
شخصًا و  الذي رأيته كان ممتلئًا ،
ألا تقلق بشأن الإصابة بالمرض ،
نعم بالطبع بالطبع
نفعل ذلك بالطريقة التي يعمل بها الفن
في إيدي ، لذا فهي حفرة
من فيروس كورونا ، إنها عشرات حرفياً  من
المرضى الإيجابيين ، يجب أن يكون الحمل الفيروسي في هذا
المكان فلكيًا ، ما الذي
تتمنى أن يفهمه جميع الأمريكيين حول
ما تمر به ، أريد حقًا
أن يأخذ الأمريكيون هذا الأمر بجدية ليعرفوا
أنه حتى لو كنت في منطقة
ليست مدينة كبيرة  مازلت  في خطر
ولا نعرف من سيصاب
بالمرض حقًا ، فهو لا يجنب أي شخص
ولا سيما معلومة واحدة أخرى واقعية
والتي د.
أخبرنا مالوي أنه من بين
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يستخدمون أجهزة التنفس الصناعي في
وحدة العناية المركزة ، لم يتم إخراج أي منهم
بنجاح من أجهزة التنفس هذه الآن
، كان المستشفى يعمل
بمائة وخمسين بالمائة من سعته
وقد انخفض هذا العدد إلى مائة و
عشرة بالمائة من سعتها لكنها
لا تزال غير مستدامة كلاريسا وارد سي إن إن
لندن